hola este es el vídeo de química
esencial número 51 y hablaremos de
calorimetría como mucho de lo que
conocemos en química esto empezó con
antón lavoisier ahora la palabra
calorimetría significa medición de calor
y el primer calorímetro creado por
lavoisier fue un calor y metro de hielo
que básicamente consistía en una cámara
aislada con hielo y rodeada por otra
cámara de hielo y lo que hacía era poner
algo en su interior como por ejemplo una
vela lo cual genera calor así se
derretirá el hielo transformándose en un
líquido que se puede medir así fue como
pudo medir el calor liberado de una vela
pero después puso algo vivo adentro usó
un conejillo de indias y descubrió que
todo ocurría de la misma forma porque el
conejillo de indias respira y esa es una
forma de combustión se toma el oxígeno y
se libera calor así que prácticamente es
el mismo proceso por lo tanto lo que
analizamos es
energía que se libera en este sistema y
miren un calorímetro es muy sencillo
solo consiste en un baño que
generalmente es agua porque sabemos cómo
cambia y después tenemos un sistema
químico que se coloca adentro de este
baño y bueno también necesitamos un
termómetro adentro del baño para medir
lo que sucede
conforme ocurren los cambios de energía
así que podemos medir el cambio de
energía de ese sistema químico y podemos
usar esto para medir cosas como la
capacidad calorífica específica o
también llamado calor específico la
entalpía de fusión y de vaporización y
también la entalpía de reacción entonces
empecemos con el agua imaginen que
tenemos un vaso con agua y le aplicamos
energía le aplicamos calor
recuerden vamos a medir qué tan fácil se
calienta o se enfría usando algo llamado
calor específico y miren el calor
específico es igual a la cantidad de
calor transferido que se miden
entre los gramos de sustancia es decir
cuánto tenemos por el cambio de
temperatura entonces cómo conocemos el
calor específico del agua que es de 4.18
jules por gramo kelvin ahora veamos un
ejemplo imaginen que tenemos 250
mililitros de agua y como es agua
podemos decir que son 250 gramos de agua
y empezamos a 18 grados celsius
entonces la masa es igual a 250 gramos y
nuestra temperatura inicial es de 18
grados celsius pero después lo
calentamos un rato y la temperatura
aumenta a 65 grados celsius entonces
nuestra temperatura final de subíndice
efe es igual a 65 grados celsius ahora
sí calculemos cuánta energía aplicamos
al sistema para eso usemos el calor
específico que ya sabemos que es igual a
la cantidad de calor transferido entre
los gramos de sus
por el cambio de temperatura entonces
usemos estos valores ya sabemos que el
calor específico del agua es 4.18 y
también sabemos que la masa de la
sustancia es de 250 gramos lo
sustituimos y también podemos conocer el
cambio de temperatura porque pasamos de
18 a 65 grados por lo tanto el cambio es
igual a la temperatura final
- la temperatura inicial es decir 65
menos 18 y eso es igual a 47 grados
celsius y luego simplemente despejamos
el calor transferido y no olvidemos
convertir los grados celsius a kelvin
simplificamos y obtenemos que la
cantidad de calor transferido es de 33
punto 46 por 10 a la 4 jules y de donde
vino esa energía claro del calentamiento
del agua entonces si sabemos cuánto
cambia la temperatura del agua y su masa
podemos calcular cuánto
energía se libera y así es como funciona
un calorímetro tenemos un recipiente en
el que ocurre la reacción o el
calentamiento o el cambio de fase y lo
colocamos adentro de este baño en el que
podremos medir los cambios de
temperatura y al medir esos cambios de
temperatura del agua podremos calcular
cuánta energía se libera o se consume en
el recipiente entonces si calentamos ese
material supongamos que es una reacción
química y observamos cambios de
temperatura podemos saber cuánto de eso
proviene de la reacción que está
ocurriendo y miren así es como se ve un
calor y metro real y lo que hacemos es
poner lo que sea que queramos estudiar
adentro de este recipiente después lo
sumergimos en agua y adentro tenemos un
termómetro muy preciso
y para que la temperatura sea homogénea
agitamos un poco el agua así medimos el
cambio de energía y podemos usar eso
para calcular el calor específico la
entalpía de fusión que
acuerden es cuando pasamos de sólido a
líquido o también para medirla entalpía
de vaporización es decir cuando pasamos
de estado líquido a gaseoso o incluso
podemos medirla entalpía de reacción
podemos medir reacciones endo térmicas o
exotérmicas esa es la función de un
calor y metro entonces aprendieron a
interpretar los resultados de un
experimento recuerden lo que buscamos
son cambios en la temperatura del agua